[Music]
yes
black holes are the monsters of the
universe
terrifying Cosmic beasts that devour all
they encounter
but black holes scare scientists for
very different reasons
they challenge our series to the
breaking point
this is at the Forefront of theoretical
physics
when it comes to the detailed nature of
black holes
it would not surprise me if we got it
all wrong
the science of black holes is so
challenging that some scientists
question whether they exist at all
[Music]
despite their fearsome reputation
we've never actually seen one
black holes are everywhere they're all
over the universe they're all throughout
our galaxy but that doesn't mean that
they're easy to find
they're black and space is black and
black on black is kind of hard to see in
a picture of space
this is paradoxical because scientists
believe black holes are born in some of
the brightest explosions in the universe
rising from the corpses of detonated
Stars many times larger than our sun
star that burns for 10 million years
collapses to form a black hole in a
period of seconds
as it collapses the outer region of the
star hits the core triggering a huge
explosion a supernova
[Music]
see the bang
what's left behind
a dead core with the enormous mass of
the star crushed down into an
infinitesimal tiny area
thank you
from this minuscule high mass core
a black hole is born
the flow of gravity is so strong that
nothing can escape not even light
[Music]
but how can scientists claim that black
holes exist if we can't even see them
[Music]
you could say that about the existence
of the atom we knew they had existed for
decades centuries before we had actually
seen one in some sort of Imaging device
and so it's the same sort of thing with
black holes
just because you can't see it doesn't
mean it's not there not seeing black
holes
that wind is there even though we can't
see air
[Music]
is invisible but when the Wind Blows Its
effects can be measured
the same with black holes you just need
to know what to look for
black holes are gravitational Giants of
the universe
but we've found only circumstantial
evidence that they exist
to make it a slam dunk cosmologists are
listening for proof
the Hidden World of gravitational waves
there are gravitational waves going
through this room all the time every
time I move my hands like I just did I
create gravitational waves the problem
is gravity is so weak that you don't
detect those gravitational waves
in order to attack those disturbances of
space and time you have to have
cataclysmic events involving massive
objects
[Music]
black holes are some of the densest
objects in the universe
so we should be able to hear and measure
the waves created when they Collide
ligo the long interferometry
gravitational wave Observatory listens
for waves that can come from over a
billion light years away
[Music]
in 2017 ligo heard an enormous crash
two very massive objects collided at
near the speed of light and one of the
most energetic events that we've ever
witnessed in the history of humankind
[Music]
Two ultra heavy ultra dense objects
whirl around each other hurling powerful
gravitational waves through space
the closer they fall toward each other
the more gravitational energy they throw
out
finally they Collide in one of the most
violent events in the universe
the smash sends out immense
gravitational waves that Ripple across
Intergalactic space
[Music]
till the eventually
ligo detects them
listening to a gravitational wave is
like listening to a musical instrument
if it's making certain tones or certain
vibrations you can figure out the size
of the musical instrument the type of
the musical instrument who's playing the
musical instrument
[Music]
the thing that's really amazing about
the ligo detection is it allowed us to
measure the mass of these objects and
how quickly they coalesce together so we
actually have an idea how dense they
must have been and with modern physics
we say Well it has to be a black hole
but the question is have we missed
something
information gathered by ligo is
groundbreaking
[Music]
but some scientists think that the
gravitational waves could have come not
from black holes but from something even
more mysterious
it's possible that what we identify as
black holes in our universe are really
another object like gravistar possible
there's a capital P on that possible
[Music]
a gravistar is what scientists call an
exotic compact object
[Music]
this bizarre theoretical body has
exactly the same mass and gravitational
pull as a black hole
but it's made of exotic matter
a gravistar would be impossible to see
with the naked eye but because it forms
differently than a black hole it has a
strange incredibly dense surface
[Music]
the formation of
think of as a black hole the cat
ons object maybe it doesn't go all the
way down to become an infinitely dense
Point instead maybe there's some
interaction that prevents the formation
of the black hole and instead you have a
tight little dense ball which is what we
call a gravistar
so the ligo data could be the signature
of two black holes colliding but it also
could be the signature of two gravis
Stars colliding right now we can't tell
them apart
[Music]
so for now gravitational waves have led
to a dead end in the hunt for black
holes
we can't be completely sure that we're
hearing them and we already know we
can't see them
but what about the Mayhem they leave
behind
even though you can't see the black hole
itself it's going to leave behind a
trail of Destruction and that is
something you can see
[Applause]
[Music]
by picking apart a cosmic crime scene
can scientists finally solve the mystery
of black holes
foreign